you know and if blue man the only way
you can tell if anybody's from blue man
is when you look in their eyes because
that's the only thing that's distinctive
from the other blue men in the group all
right we've got some blue in the sky
and we've also got some clouds and some
early light interesting too
smoke trail as we look out off to the
east there
looks like something was launched from
the skies so we're going to check that
out see what's going on over there
we've got temperatures right now in the
low 40s a very light west wind at five
and 19 is the dew point but there's just
really no moisture in our air
with the clouds that we've seen mid to
high level clouds and
that just has not increased our relative
humidity or put any moisture in our air
at all lots of
cool 30s in the south valley for sure
nellis is even down to 31 aliante in the
north end is at 39
seven hills at 34 this morning it's been
freezing in prom
kingman definitely cold january morning
and cold enough for coats so please
don't forget those
nice warm jacket if you're heading out
snow just south of st
louis through the mid-south and below
that to
the gulf coast they've got thunderstorms
this morning no rain really left on the
west coast the interior west has some
snow showers
and these clouds are very harmless for
us a lot of cloud cover though
still coming in to the west coast just
bands and bands of heavier clouds
they seem to thin out quite a bit by the
time they get to the desert but
we'll look for heavier clouds again
tonight mostly sunny skies for your
thursday
good breaks of sunshine today and highs
that will reach again see if we can make
the low 60s
again yesterday just 59. we'll look for
early morning clouds then more sunshine
through your friday
saturday we get those north winds with a
cold front
that will cool us to the 50s for a day
before a big warm up next week
with mid to upper 60s and again staying
very dry